you
[Music]
hello and welcome to the dead stream my
name is Susie and I will be your host
this episode and I am joined this
afternoon by the fluff of nightmares
ladies white rabbit hello thanks for
having me
we are also joined tonight by the third
voice of death mortis media hey guys
you're listening to episode 2 of the
dead stream so how you guys doing yeah
I'm good what about you rub it hey do or
right doing pretty well as well I'm
probably gonna go after this stream and
head over to the it's me Bolthouse over
in Hollywood check that out maybe some
some footage for the channel very good
house yeah it's like a haunted house
based on the it movie that's coming up
as far as I can tell oh man did not know
that
yeah which was funny because I came out
with that video where I was saying like
my ideas if they were to put it at
Halloween Horror Nights and then don't
turn around he's actually in the
comments right now so shout out to him
he let me know about this house that
they're actually holding in Hollywood so
I'm gonna go check that out tonight with
West Dakota frac toyed films and orange
studios it's so cool oh I don't know
exactly like what it is I'm assuming
it's just like a haunted house where
they pop out at you and stuff but then I
also read on the website that they have
that they allow flash photography so I
don't know if it's like if it's
something where people are gonna be
popping out at you or if it's more of
like just come from room to room and see
what's going on type of thing are you
guys excited about it I am increasingly
more excited for it with every room
advertisement that I say okay so - I
really really keen on seeing it I'm not
sure if I should
read the book or watch the previous ones
first or if I just should go in knowing
nothing about it yeah other than what
I've seen on your channel is easy right
it's pretty good by the way but I'm not
sure but I aren't excited for it
nonetheless and this other film I keep
seeing appetizer Flatliners seems pretty
interesting the whole concept of life
after death and being dead for a few
minutes and stuff coming back from the
dead told you it seems yeah that really
cool as well have you seen the original
Flatliners I didn't even know that it
was an original know that yeah I didn't
know either at first but yeah apparently
that one's a remake as well alright so
in the combo is in the chat let it let
us know if we need to see the original
flat and eyeliners first and let us know
like your opinion should Mort read the
book or watch the original miniseries
before he sees it it might be
interesting if like I go into it with me
having like read the book and seen the
miniseries and you go into it as your
first experience to the franchise and
then we can talk about it on the dead
stream like from different perspectives
mm-hmm shout out to orange studios in
the chat right now he is one of the guys
that I'm going to the house later with
we also did a collab over on his channel
that I'm in which I recommend checking
guys you guys checking out it is all
right you guys know like that snapchat
hot dog filter yeah it's basically like
um like a Gore movie involving us versus
the hot dog those sound quite
entertaining yeah it came out really
well too it's it's pretty funny we just
kind of like made it up as we went and
it kind of worked all right so what do
you get a few guys released this month
you have any projects that you want to
talk about well I've just been trying to
release you know different scary story
videos everyday trying to do a few
hour-long ones because people keep
asking for them but
they fail to see that it takes so so
long to physically do this like it's
like 8 to 10 hours to make a whole hour
long video it's just crazy the amount of
work that has to go into making I see
some people uploading hour-long every
day I'm just like wow the commitment the
commitment is there yeah just that
really yesterday was fishing struggle
this morning with fishing stories pretty
pretty weird never expected to have
paranormal fishing stories but it's a
thing and I suppose something
interesting that happened lately is my
fans I bet one I bet my fans that they
couldn't rob they said if my comment
gets 20 likes
can I have hemorrhoid stories and I said
ok and and it got like 27 like says they
all know I'm gonna have to make a video
on hemorrhoid stories and I did it's
just so great they're funny but pretty
grim yeah you gotta be careful what you
what you say on the Internet where if
you're if you're bargaining likes and
stuff like that before we get to you
rabbit I got to give a shout out a shout
out to Chad in the chat he is the DP of
the webseries life as a mermaid it's an
excellent webseries I actually do sound
for them from time to time as well so I
rabbit what have you been working on um
I'm just trying to keep up with stories
I've got in the wings waiting I really
want to start doing some more true
stories of history horror in history I
just need to come up with another
subject that I'll be passionate about
researching but as always I'll have
another story got tomorrow I had to take
a week off due to some deep monetization
issues with YouTube but I will be back
tomorrow
so when you say history like how how
deep in the history are you planning on
going like 20 years back a hundred years
back or is it just gonna be all over the
place
yeah I don't have like a time frame as
long as it's I mostly want to focus on
human error that caused a bunch of
devastation so like the two stories I've
done already are Chernobyl and Centralia
I was really into even the radium girls
but just basically messed up things that
happened in history that either set in
motion some laws or devastated a whole
city somehow yeah I mean human subjects
yeah human errors probably like the
scariest thing that can happen like
outside of natural disasters yeah sure
sure yeah it's like something I learned
in history class actually like in what
what Hitler was in World War one and
apparently a British soldier instead of
shooting him actually came to his aid
and you know helped him and he made a
full recovery cuz I think he was shot or
injured and if we had just shot him or
if you just done nothing yeah you know
the biggest mass genocide ever would
have never happened it's just like this
is one tiny thing this one moment oh
yeah yeah fascinating to me and it makes
for some really interesting stories that
you don't necessarily hear about in
school and I think it could be more fun
to learn it on a horror channel no
exactly yeah I completely agree yeah and
I think just presenting it in that way
like when you edit it and add music to
it if you're creating suspense it makes
learning things about history like a lot
more interesting sure I think I would
have wanted to learn about a lot more of
this stuff back then if I didn't have to
read out of a textbook right and much
would have much rather heard it in a
more entertaining way which you can
absolutely find on YouTube now so
speaking of natural disasters rabbit
you've got to be dying right now
so it's 104 degrees outside for me so I
can only imagine how bad it is for you
right now
yeah it's a it's a good 115 here and we
recently we recently discovered that
there are rotting pipes in our walls
that are destroying our ACS so I don't
have any air conditioning either
no I hope delightful oh yeah I can't
wait to get out of this apartment so
next episode on the bet on the dead
stream I will be joined by mortis media
and a puddle a furry bottle
yeah I'm going to Atlanta next week to
visit Dragon Con for five days and I
will be thrilled to be out of this heat
right well I mean Atlantis probably not
as hot as where you are but mmm I
imagine it's still gonna be quite muggy
I don't know if you're used to the
humidity down there either but yeah I
just I'm gonna be staying inside mostly
at least there's air conditioning in the
hotels so last episode we briefly talked
about don't hug me I'm scared
Mort did you get around to watching that
one I've watched the first two and I'm
gonna be honest at first I thought it
was like a like a kid show no this looks
like a kid shows it's pretty pretty
weird and then it escalated and they
were frying hearts or and like the pie
was blood the time one
it was started all off happy and quickly
the descent into madness and it's just
funny how they do these quick what's the
well how they quickly change it how they
make it look happy but they throw little
digs they throw things in that kind of
making at the start especially for me
because I haven't seen it before like
when they were getting creative it was
like ah isn't a create color and then so
you had seen the first episode prior to
the last Oh obviously I seen one and two
since then it's pretty it's pretty weird
okay so like what's your opinion of them
like obviously you knew that like we
wanted you to watch it so obviously you
knew it just wasn't a straight-up show
right I really like it it's freaky it's
it's really different so I'm definitely
gonna be watching the remaining few over
the next few days but it certainly
grabbed my attention to say the least
burn in the comments brings up night
mind has this really great don't hug me
i'm scared analysis video and me and
rabbit we're just talking about that
earlier like we could probably do a
whole episode just talking about like oh
yeah i don't know more have you picked
up on any of like the symbolism and
hidden meetings behind the series yet or
are you just kind of taking it in
anything i can't i can't possibly
imagine what is he trying to think on
the spot mmm
watches pick up all you little things
yeah probably watch it and then maybe
I'll understand once I've watched a good
tooth which was maybe that's what dead
stream episode 3 can be the whole
analysis of yeah like I said we could do
it like really an entire episode on it
did I bring it up last time how I went
to the panel and then people were trying
to ask them like the meaning behind
everything really
don't turn around in the chat says he
accidentally close the window and came
back and had an ad for Victoria and
Abdul I'm not sure what that is do you
guys know what that is no all right
don't turn around let me know let me
know about that um
someone else in the chat is asking what
I thought about Death Note did you guys
get a chance to see that yet no okay
I'll keep it brief then I will say that
I didn't think it was bad it definitely
is kind of like a dumbed down version
for like wider audiences um I didn't
hate it as much as everybody did and I
thought it was I thought it was
entertaining and I'm a huge Death Note
fan so should we move on oh yeah so the
though in the last
episode we talked about the donut cop
stereotype mm-hmm
rabbit I believe it was the story that
you were reading and we were wondering
like where that came from
yeah so I looked it up and apparently
that came from the idea that cops don't
really have like a lot of options when
they're doing the late-night shifts to
get food or at least like a lot of a lot
of restaurants and fast food places are
open 24 hours now but back in the day
they were it was basically just diners
and doughnut shops so if they want to if
they wanted to get a coffee to keep
themselves away through the night shift
then that was the hole yeah and I assume
it's part of is a lot of them are
patrolling in a car and they can't
exactly sit down and eat somewhere so
they have to eat something that's mobile
right yeah that makes sense too but it's
still a funny stereotype actually see
I've got a question for you so you
watched um the The Dark Tower film and
you didn't like it with that much yeah I
wasn't a huge fan of it there was some
really cool references to other Stephen
King movies but as a movie I just don't
feel like very much happened and like
there wasn't a whole lot of their
characters weren't that interesting in
me they were just kind of like these
super-powered beings and then you got
the kid I suppose in a way you all right
but still for a friend like a good two
hours for me it was just good to sit
back and you know not be bored I thought
it was okay good yeah I mean yeah I
think the cast was really good but just
the story for me and I haven't read The
Dark Tower series mm-hmm I've just read
a comment me I just read a couple of the
books that like it references and stuff
I mean I got a huge kick out of all of
the shining references well what were
they like if you can just quickly recap
because I just I didn't catch any just
the top after top of my head at the very
beginning
the movie it shows what is the area
called like the other dimension oh yeah
there were these twins there who said
come play with us and then in in
someone's room there was a framed
picture of the Overlook Hotel from
Kubrick's The Shining and then just the
fact that he has the power of the
shining as like one of his powers oh
yeah I see what you mean there are some
other references to um like I can talk
about the it stuff but I don't want to
go into spoiler territory so this might
not be met if you guys want to see me
talk about that in a video let me know
in the chat did you catch don't I did
you catch don't turn arounds reply at
all he says it's a period picture movie
alright so by the way we tried last
episode there were some people in the
chat talking about trying discord as
opposed to Skype and we did a practice
run a couple weeks ago and didn't get
great results from discord and I mean we
pretty much all agreed that the audio
quality on skype was a lot better and
yeah absolutely yeah yeah so if you guys
have any tips for like changing the
settings on discord to get better
results let us know let's jump into the
news Mort do you wanna head up that
first headline so tobe Hooper died this
morning from Texas Chainsaw Massacre
poltergeist and Salem's Lot sometimes I
don't know about you guys but
poltergeist is one of my top favorite
horror movies obviously we're talking
about the original for those of you who
saw the remake and don't know that
there's a
[Music]
original and have you guys seen Salem's
Lot you know a long time ago I would
think I think I saw while it goes well I
can't weird you remember it all that
well mm-hmm I can when I saw the matrix
you know other good classic films right
I would say that's probably in my top
ten favorite Stephen King movies I was
surprised to see not a whole lot of
references in The Dark Tower to that one
actually have you seen all the Stephen
King films no no there's no way I think
there's close to a hundred really wow I
didn't even know that though that many
don't turn around again I'm saying it I
love to return to Salem's Lot I actually
have not seen that so maybe that's
something that would be worth checking
out before the next episode what are you
gonna say more no I was gonna say they
they're making a ship Texas Chainsaw
Massacre prequel called called Levithan
Leatherface to to describe his origin
stories it's gonna be out thing in a few
months so right yes tobe Hooper actually
is the executive producer on that
project Oh or was I should say yeah I
mean he's still will be but are you guys
it's big Texas Chainsaw fans I've seen
the number of a might I don't find them
extremely remarkable I actually like the
true story that it's emulating a little
bit more Mart well I'm gonna be honest
I'm yet to see them they're in my DVD
collection I'll buy it but I just
haven't watched it yet yeah I mean
that's something that kind of happens
when you get into making videos is you
spend so much time making stuff that you
never get around watching stuff I really
relate I bought all these games
they're just sitting there on the shelf
they've been there for about five years
I'm gonna play these eventually yes
because it's like so much and sometimes
they get people asking me like to talk
about horror games on the channel and
it's something that I want to do and
whenever I play horror games I usually
enjoy them but there's just something
that takes a little bit more time to get
into Haley Bailey asks which games so cz
um like somebody's asking me about the
new Resident Evil I guess there's like a
Resident Evil VR now which is supposedly
really good well it's seven I don't know
if it's I think it's like its own
installment okay because I know 7 has a
VR motor and it kind of just looks like
it was something they tacked on to it in
my opinion huh you might the game is
really good I mean I'm sure it's
terrifying I've never seen it VR before
and I know they have a long way to go
before the games look and feel
absolutely incredible right now I just
kind of feel like it's a weird gimmick
that they're attaching to games but
where the Naples 7 is great just short
marks at your YouTube space do they have
like the VR happy hours they had a video
course or this last Wednesday actually I
was considering going but then I was
like well when am I gonna use VR on my
videos so I didn't bother but I think
they've run them every month so I have
taken a lot of the 360 courses that they
offer and I was actually thinking about
incorporating like a 360 set up into
aldente creepypasta would be pretty
sweet I'm not gonna I'm not gonna spill
the beans I'm not exactly yet but I
think that possibly exist cool but yeah
there was an event recently where all of
these VR developers came and so we got
to demo the stuff that they're working
on now and I was really impressed by it
I can I can really see that taking
yeah I hope it does so other news mr.
creepypasta has opened a patreon and I
don't know about you guys but I mean
it's good to see that he is gonna be
able to be supported in like more
reliable ways than YouTube obviously but
to me just seeing that he opened that is
like really scary things like that when
that high up needs to have extra support
it really is I mean it's you don't it
doesn't make everyone underneath it on
that the things really is bad right
because like I mean I'm I mean I
actually tried something just to see if
I could report on it I left like hoorah
you know the word [ __ ] around like
horror stories and horrors I think in my
keywords and a video died predicted
would do quite well you know barely you
know a video I'm expecting to get about
10k views barely pulled about three
within the first day and then like six
within the second and the moment I took
them off I swear within about five hours
it jumped about eight so it's just I
don't know I don't know if it's just
coincidence I probably needs a bit more
research but and I think they may have
had a point with the horror thing cuz
now that I've had a little go I don't
really want to try again because I
because I hope you know I hope that just
by taking off it means the videos would
be more successful but I don't know for
me at least I'm sort of convinced that
you know they are targeting horror a bit
more a bit more thoroughly well it would
be nice if they told you exactly what
the offending property was like if they
could exactly if you got something to
monetize yes they could highlight like
okay it was this tag or it was this
section of the video from like three
minutes and five seconds to three
minutes and ten seconds exactly I just
wish they could be transparent being
like listen guys we no longer want this
or we'd rather you did this because this
is
happened instead of being like things
have changed we're not going to tell you
what's changed something's changed
best of luck trainer and now we're not
gonna tell you but you figured that out
by yourselves and you know will punish
you will more take your monetization
away then we'll just see what happens
really would you see and it may go good
for you it may go bad for you but you
know we're not been really gonna tell
you either way it's like a game it's
like a cruel cruel game yeah it's like
it's a very frustrating thing and that's
interesting what's been happening to my
channel lately is they're taking away
monetization from very random videos
including my Q&A which isn't even a
story it has no horror in the tags or
anything it's just my Q&A thank you
video they took that away and then you
can manually tell them to review in
order to put them back which is gonna
take like a month or two and by then it
won't matter they're doing is they're
taking away my monetization when I
upload and then maybe like a week later
they're putting it back for no reason
so after all my views that are now not
getting any kind of monetization they're
suddenly putting them back but there's
another reason for it I haven't changed
anything so I don't get it
I did hear that if you dispute something
it should come up or it should be
resolved within a day as opposed to a
month I haven't had to do that yet so I
don't know if there's any truth to that
yeah I don't know I just I wish I knew
why if they could just tell us what
we're doing wrong I'm sure a lot of us
would just alter what we're doing so
that they could be happy with this but
they won't give us that and it's really
frustrating I feel like we can do a
horror movie out of this like all of the
YouTube horror creators are just put in
this giant maze every time we do
something offending just drops and
crushes us like we get picked off by
like carnivorous rays Ravens or
something like that
nope didn't like that tag you put on
your video yeah I should write that down
it's a good idea for a collab I love it
yeah Halloween collab featuring everyone
everyone died yeah yeah nobody wins No
you YouTube wins saw 27 narrators is
what Harry speaking of harry reid's he
says we need to make Kinder Surprise egg
horror stories do you guys know what is
that I think no horror story material I
mean I bought those I've got like
princess things I mean who wants
princess things that's a whole we're not
allowed we're not allowed to have them
in our country doesn't make be banned
kinder it's a chocolate egg with a
little toy inside you don't know America
was like we don't want to give chocolate
to kids that have stuff inside them so
they banned it I've always wanted a
kinder egg there's actually one in my
fridge right now oh my golly go send it
here
yeah I mean that just says a lot about
our country I think like we can't even
be trusted to have a toy in our
chocolate egg yeah yeah I know our kids
here gonna just swallow them all in your
cereal yeah yeah I just think it's a
specific we can't have stuff inside and
encase chocolate egg or something it's
like a plastic so you know you buy into
the chocolate there's a plastic egg
inside and you have to open the plastic
egg and get the parts which are in us
yeah it's just ridiculous I mean Mort
you have to keep in mind like this is
the same country that had an epidemic of
kids who are getting lead poisoning from
like eating the paint on their toys well
not really much to say about that yeah
shame really but yeah maybe that's what
I'll do maybe I'll do a kinder giveaway
and send them all illegally to you guys
yes yes please I've always wanted one
rabbit can you type something in the
chat I just want to see something real
quick because when more posted earlier
it didn't look like he was a moderator
okay you're so you're still a moderator
but more I added last time I thought
no yeah it shows up to me that is
screwdriver the spanner next to me yeah
moderator says moderator well I just add
again I don't know I don't know why it
took yours away but it left rabbits
special get your act together YouTube so
more do you want to talk about the
circle-jerk comments yeah I mean I saw
this thing between unison unit and
darkness prevails talking about the
youtube circle gherkin I don't really
understand what it meant I had these
guys explain to me what cynical joke was
maybe you'd want to remind me how would
you explain it rabbit I can't remember
the context of my what unit was saying
but I think the point of what he was
mentioning is a bunch of people I don't
know I need do we have the the tweet
that unit said I'm just getting up no
the thing is he completes a lot so woman
yeah well I asked him about it actually
read out first for context there are
some people who think that being a part
of the quote horror community means that
you have to take part in this circle
jerk no thanks I'll pass
- which darkness prevails replies
circle-jerk how about we respect each
other and not be dicks it's pretty easy
people and then they then he replies
there's a whole thing I kind of respect
an hour express my honest opinion and
darkness chimes in I don't know who said
what but I'm behind you all the way if
someone's being an [ __ ]
good luck so I don't really know what
that means but if you would care to
elaborate well um for those of you who
are confused I guess circle-jerk is not
like a recognized term in England but
anyway I asked him about the about what
he meant by that he said because I
thought he was talking about like the
mega collaborations where you have 50
people narrating in one video and it's
like
but he said no he's totally for the make
collaborations he was talking about he
was criticized for criticizing another
narrator and people thought that he was
trying to start drama oh I see it now
see the light oh yeah what's your guy's
opinion on YouTube drama it's always
it's always gonna be there I mean I'm
like I'm so sick of people covered
saying uh Jake Paul or Logan Paul and
here in England there's this other
youtuber called ksi I don't if he
alright well he's actually here oh yeah
I know he just lives quite close to me
and apparently he's got like a little
group and he then said something about
the group and now he's doing a diss
track about someone in the group they're
basically recreating some stuff that's
happening with the Logan Paul yeah
thanks that's going on I don't really
know and it's all just to get views and
likes and money and I guess first I
guess where I'm going with this is do
you think that that kind of stuff is
manufactured for views and do you think
that's something that could be going on
in the horror community as well I think
it is manufactured for views a lot I
think once it I think when it happens
for example let's say it happens without
this whole Logan poor thing I'm not even
sure what it is
my sister-in-law tried to explain it to
me about this girl and I can't really
remember the details but anyway that
anyways no and and then and then and
then you know she said no and now ksi is
doing with this thing and it's obviously
the same thing and they're just
reproducing what's happened in America
because they want the views and the
money and I'm saying well yeah it's
obvious it's really disappointing that
people you know stoop so low for
attention and I don't think it's really
happening in the horror horror community
yeah but I'm saying that I think that
five to two right that unit five T to
manufactured no no I'm just saying I
I don't really think we're the kind of
community that really seeks to expose
and dramatize stuff because I just don't
think we're those kind of people we're
too interested in telling horror stories
and not generating lame horror stories
yeah I mean I can tell I think that we
have one of the most tight-knit
communities on YouTube I don't really
see other YouTube communities doing
collabs like we do and like actively
engaging with each other on Twitter in
the comments and it's like a staple in
the horror community you need to work
with other people well you don't need
everyone just doesn't it's I think it's
fantastic it's like a little family yeah
and when you see people uploading horror
content like their subscribers are
usually very supportive you don't see
like a lot of videos getting hate
exactly everyone how great job I've
really loved this one keep it up
no one's like oh yeah you're terrible
please quit I'm watching I'm disliking
this because I hate you no one says that
it's it's nice it's a nice little safe
community don't you agree rabbit oh yeah
for sure I was noticing that even if is
you just talk about the fanbase I've got
some of the nicest fans I've ever seen
whereas if you go on other YouTube
channels you know whatever the style is
that they're doing they'll attract
different kinds of fans and I just I
think ours is one of the coolest
communities so secondly all right from
Matt should we talk about the be best of
stuff I'm gonna attempt to fill our
viewers who aren't totally familiar with
the situation in on it but I may be
missing stuff because there's a lot of
stuff that went down in the last month
so he be Busta a YouTube narrator over
500,000 subscribers he stopped he
basically stopped doing YouTube and said
that he was going to completely switch
to twitch and he had this deal with them
that if he could bring a certain amount
of people over to twitch then they would
have him under contract so he basically
said that he wasn't gonna be uploading
his videos to YouTube anymore and he was
talking about how like he never wanted
to open a patreon because he didn't want
his fans to feel like they owed him
something but like he's just got to the
point where he had to and like his
notifications weren't going out to his
subscribers he couldn't contact anyone
from YouTube so he made this move to
twitch and then two days later he goes
back on his claim and saying that he was
saying that YouTube was starting to
offer more transparency and with the
whole update how you could dispute the
copy or not the copyright the
monetization claims that he may consider
putting some stuff back on YouTube but
that I think about it might have
something to do with him going over 500k
and then people unsubscribing in him
dipping back under mmhmm and him being
like oh I better pick this up boy okay I
agree but the thing is he he actually he
handled these videos on on his channel
and then he announced everything and he
said what from now on I'm also going to
be uploading to YouTube but it's just
gonna be my live streams to you know
redirect you guys I think he had his
first live stream up there and then he
deleted the video explaining everything
that he was leaving he deleted the live
stream and you know if you just look at
his videos I he's like he's lost five
videos a recent well ish he's got a
video from a month ago then two weeks
then one week five days three days three
hours so he's he's uploading again you
know regularly to his channel he's come
back but I I don't know I haven't been
through his Twitter feed and I haven't
um I know I might have missed a video
which he's already deleted but he's
certainly
seemingly back what is going on in the
chat right now it's a lot of hi hello
hello to everybody in the chat
line Atwater's harry reid's killer dog
israel 100 israel hello to everybody
hello everyone so I think that the way
that be bust handled the situation again
like I like to be bust I like his
content I think is a cool guy I don't
think you handled the situation very
well at all he put so much effort into
saying that he was done on YouTube and
the reasons that he was done on YouTube
were not because he wasn't making money
according to him but because he was just
fed up with the way that he was treated
by YouTube so for him to go into twitch
weeks and then come back well at some
point he did make the comment that I I
would have to get a full-time job and if
that was the case I would only be
uploading once every other week and I
know people won't like that I've got a
couple of issues with that comment
mainly being a lot of us small channels
like myself have a full-time job and I
still manage to get videos out there or
try to once a week and the other thing
is so you're saying you could only put
videos out once every other week and
your fans won't like that so your
alternative is just quitting altogether
that seemed a little contradicting to me
I mean it's a bit it's not you know like
he built up this huge audience and then
to say to them well you know if I have
to get a job like everyone else does
lots of smaller channels do then you
know the I'm gonna have to do this very
very infrequently I mean I'm I'm fit
under the philosophy that you know if
you want something you really have to
work hard to get it and I mean he's like
you know he's effectively got it but he
still has to work hard to maintain it
but yeah like I'm I completely
understand you because I'm under getting
home like it 8 and thinking oh man I'm
now gonna spend the next four hours
making a video my weekend you say yeah
yeah yeah right it's it's possible
put the working you know who else
uploads every other week a lot of people
do for example mr. nightmare pretty much
uploads every other week nobody dislikes
exactly he's one of the most popular
guys around yeah yeah doesn't he have
like two point mm no like two point four
lost summer trip and make sure he's be
the most popular guy but yeah I think
he's like right up there next to him
yeah two point six damn yeah let me just
check Rob so we can have the undisputed
king oh wait hold on two point six three
people Oh mr. nightmares got 20k more oh
really I've loaded video last week on a
million years must be nice but we should
probably clarify that's only for English
channels oh yeah of course there was a
comment a little while back from orange
studios and he said that the kinder eggs
are gonna be back in 2018 awesome I'm
buying them all I mean I still don't
know how how that would spin into a
horror story but I'm sure we can get
creative with that stuff you pull out
the Kendricks as the real horror yeah
yeah yeah yeah just don't try to eat
them like a snake hole and I'm sure
you'll be fine
[Laughter]
Italy there would be about the stuff
that comes out of the eggs or like the
people who try to swallow it whole I'm
concerned about those people I mean that
would make a funny horror narration
though I was I got my kindred egg in the
mail after waiting for two long years
for them to come back and accept Arizona
so whoever lives there
I apologize yeah yeah
a little melt here anyway it's fun true
um
so back him to be busted thing I don't
know I felt like the initial video he
did it was 24 minutes long and like the
first 17 minutes of it was just him kind
of moping around and I don't know it
kind of felt like he was trying to get
sympathy but for you to basically change
your entire focus of your content moving
to another platform he puts up this 24
minute video and he doesn't get to the
point that he's moving platforms until
17 minutes into the video exactly it was
very very just saying the same thing
about 15 times okay now moving it which
I think he's a great guy and you know I
love his work as well but yeah the way
he handled himself was a bit hmm not the
best and then yeah that's just the fact
that it seems he deleted those videos I
know exactly so it seems like he's
trying to erase the fact that oh yeah
he's like exactly no um I never said
that what obviously not but you know is
he put maybe he maybe you never know
maybe it was just a ploy to get lots of
people on his twitch so that way he gets
you know effectively a boost so he can
have the people on twitch and you know
like thing in the morning to him that
would be interesting yeah but you know I
don't know I mean he uploads every three
days and if he's doing this full-time
and he only makes a 20 minute video
every three days I mean I can make it
twenty minute video every day okay so
maybe one day YouTube one date which one
day break I mean I don't know but maybe
conspiracy if there is okay what do you
guys think about using other platforms
in general well I see other people
uploading two vids dot me have you seen
that rabbit you used it I have only
heard of it what about you cz yeah I
actually have a channel on vid me where
I have been uploading some of my stuff
not to try to grow an audience
there but just kind of as a backup in
case something always good on YouTube I
mean 90% of the content and I have a
couple friends who have kind of focused
more of their content on attracting Vimy
users but 90% of the content that gets
popular and Vimy is content that's
popular because it's hating on YouTube
so oh I mean I take a secondary option
yeah and I definitely don't hate YouTube
like I have a lot of issues with it but
I mean I think anybody who focuses their
life on something is going to have
criticisms but also YouTube has done a
lot for me oh yeah yeah definitely is
it's so you I mean I'm such a small
channel starting off anywhere like I
started putting some of my stuff on
soundcloud so people could listen to me
offline and it just it gets no followers
because I so I don't want to spread
myself too thin and be all over the
place but on one platform that's the
thing that I worry about with doing with
doing other platforms is I'm afraid that
I'm gonna have half of my people coming
on YouTube and then half of my people
coming on another platform and then I'm
not gonna have like the sufficient
traffic on YouTube to get it to where
like picks it up or it's trending and by
splitting myself up right yeah you know
like really be successful on one of them
how they get her rather focus all my my
important stuff on on youth ideally I
would figure out a way to have different
content for different platforms oh yeah
I mean I suppose that's what people are
doing with twitch they'll do like a game
stream even though they narrate horror
stories somewhere else
so I that's important right it seems
kind of like a fallback for people to do
like a game stream as their as their
secondary content oh yeah but I was
talking with some other horror channels
recently and we were talking about how
Facebook is now offering like a creative
platform essentially and some people
were saying like yeah you should be
uploading your stuff to Facebook so you
can get ahead of the curve so if that
blows up then you'll be there for the
beginning of it but also like I was
saying earlier like how then can you
spread yourself sure yeah exactly I mean
I remember a few years I last year I was
considering uploading to Facebook
sharing my videos on Facebook but you
know they keep all the monetization but
now if they've got an option but is only
for like at the top creators right now
and they might roll it out some more
people later but even said my even so I
mean Facebook I mean the way Facebook
works and the way I mean I hardly use it
but my wife ezel at the time and she's
like she scrolls through it if you see
something interesting she was stopped
and she watch it for a few seconds and
then she finds an interesting show
watching if she doesn't scroll on and I
assume that's Facebook for most people I
just can't see my video but I'd be like
popping up the intro playing and by the
time the intro is done I mean oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah and it quite unlikely that
it'll I'll ever be found or discovered
or remotely appreciated on the platform
unless there's a specific page for
videos you might be interested in and
Maltese media uploaded a video which
mm-hmm the other thing about Facebook is
the content that goes viral on there is
so trashy exactly certain it's like oh
like for example today there was a game
a tourist because like the only phone
theory worth reading about is about
samwell tarly and Game of Thrones and
and I said to my wife now that that's
just gonna be try yeah and it's also
hard to support spam sorry you cut out
there for a second
yo yeah but it's hard to support a
platform that's there's so much stolen
content on Facebook
oh yeah the stuff I see is stuff that's
ripped from YouTube and then they put
like the big black bars to make the
video is square and remember like the
text over the top of it
like you won't believe this video about
IHS bass take your your your things you
missed on it video you know do that on
Facebook you probably wouldn't even know
and it gets like a massive amount of
news because that video was great cz I
loved all of them
thank you but it could happen and you
know yeah me P I'm making a note to
myself now to check facebook and make
sure that hasn't already I did actually
see an article things you missed in the
it trailers and I was like that's a
that's kind of interesting topic because
so yesterday I uploaded a new things you
missed on the Death Note movie and I was
going to do my tags and I typed things
you missed into the search just to try
to find some relevant tags and there's
like a whole genre of things you missed
videos now yeah it's so weird like I
don't know oh I don't know if I'm the
first one to brand my content like that
as things you missed but it seems like
ever since I came out with that video
that everyone is trying to get on things
you missed right now yeah you can see
BuzzFeed every BuzzFeed things you
missed in every film ever yeah yeah
don't turn around I think has a good
comment he got ripped to videos ripped
from Facebook one at 14 million I had
nine million nine billion nine million
views and get them taken down is on
prices now bro I can imagine story about
that well that's the other thing about
Facebook is the things that get a lot of
views the how Facebook identifies if you
is if you've seen it for like a second
on YouTube you have to watch it for a
certain amount of time before actually
registers as a view so when people am
scrolling by and see like part of a
video on Facebook and then they scroll
past to it after a second that counts as
a view yeah so that's why you see videos
with a ridiculous amount of views now my
friend its Brent when we were talking
with some of the other horror channels
recently was saying that you should
embrace that because if you upload your
film to Facebook
a bunch of people scroll past it and a
few people share it and it gets like six
million views then you can go to a
company when you're pitching your bigger
project and say like hey this got six
million views and they don't know the
difference they don't understand that
Facebook News means nothing I suppose
that's true but I think it really
depends on the kind of like for you for
example it could work and maybe for
rabbits documentary stuff because you
know maybe cuz you go into a lot of
in-depth investigation but for some you
know for other members of the whole
community just just wouldn't really be
feasible well yeah I mean for you it
would be very hard because I think the
gimmick with Facebook is that the videos
will autoplay with no sound but if
you're doing Conte if you're doing
narration content that relies on sound
that much yeah won't work all right
shall we jump into the stories before we
didn't even talk about the tcri
narrations thing do you guys want to
talk about that or start reading this
story really save it for next time if
you guys want to which one oh I think I
think I touched on it but if you want I
can just quickly explain it okay do you
guys mind if we go a little bit over an
hour no I don't care yeah discuss
alright just basically that quickly
reading narrations who changed his name
from that creepy reading to TCR
narrations because you know creepy could
you know could potentially be targeted
made a video called apple juice dot avi
history he's talking about targeted for
D monetization by the way yeah exactly
yeah
sorry yeah exactly and he yeah blurred
it had nothing to do with horror
you know just had a few tags in it that
could be like um creepy read it that
creepy readings I think those are is
only text one day yeah and well the
video was just a meme too there was no
audio it was just there was nothing was
like the sky reacting to some other
video it was some great day under a meme
or something like that
and and yeah just got D monetized for no
reason and he was just explaining how
you know just because he's
he's a horror channel and because he got
the tags that is it just gets brought
down and targeted which is so
disappointing because it's like there's
no reason whatsoever for this video to
be targeted tool there's nothing there's
nothing there and it just gets shut down
like that
so again level so his hypothesis was
that because he had the word creepy in
the tags which is really the only bit of
metadata that could have been targeted
that he thinks that the word creepy will
get you d monetize no matter what
exactly which that might be true for his
channel actually but I use the word
creepy in my tags quite frequently and I
haven't gotten those videos to monetize
so yeah I don't know I think maybe they
target specific channels on specific
words now once you're in there I I think
they're gonna have their eye on you
depending on what you say of what you do
but you know when you're outside their
radar maybe you're good that's an
interesting I have a little clip of T
Sara narrations video that I'm gonna
play right now it's just a joke there's
probably worse things on PewDiePie
videos so why don't I quickly go here to
basic info to maybe figure out what
exactly I could have put in here that
would have caused it the trip apple
juice that a bi apple juice is life the
dot avi thing is a craze that's going on
other than that I don't really see what
the issue is there that creepy reading
that was my youtube channel name before
the whole YouTube ad pocalypse it I was
warned that that might trigger the thing
or make me not get as many ads overall
so I stopped my channel name of a PCR
narration and yeah here we are the word
creepy makes this video not advertiser
friendly so again it's just like if they
had some kind of transparency as to
where they could tell us why something's
getting demonetized
it would I mean it would benefit them as
well yeah I don't understand what the
point of keeping it from all of us it is
because if they could just tell us what
to do we'd be happy to do it I'm sure
what is this thing that just went on the
chat about toast I was just trying to
fill space but by engaging our audience
in a toast yet so then after that Vidya
dropped he posted a comment update this
was two weeks ago and he said he talked
to someone at YouTube
well here here was his comment update
most of my LNM content was approved
after appealing the YouTube content
shiznit if you guys are confused Ellen
I'm content is let's not mean it's a
subreddit where a lot of nari just
pulled their scary stories from he said
he had a call with someone at Google and
they've made huge strides in getting
horror back on YouTube hash keep YouTube
creepy so that's that's good to hear I
would love to hear more details about
that in the future all right so we're at
56 minutes so far what do you guys say
we just read the second story and then
we can save that longer audio story for
next time
sounds good to me all right so the story
is I saw a dead body when I was four
this was submitted by Murph and his his
Twitter handle is at sur mer faintin and
Mort is going to read this story he
there mark did we lose morg oh no sorry
back from the dead yes all right okay my
preschool was taking a walk in the woods
and I thought I saw a man covered in mud
comes out it was a dead body covered in
a D Pokkiri yeah what is that
I would specify when one wasn't I walked
over the body even though the teacher
told me not to and I was sitting there
poking it with a stick for five minutes
Clara funk you wanna add a post sear I
don't care I'll play the pronunciation
of it is a grayish waxy substance storm
formed by the decomposition of soft
tissue in dead bodies subjected to
moisture oh well very specific very
specific right I was sitting there
poking it with a stick for five minutes
until one of them picked me up and
carried me back to the group this is a
story another movie the next day I found
another dead body this went on for about
two weeks in the same woods the cops
came one day into the woods and we
didn't take a walk in the woods for
about a month God where are these woods
cops so long to show up it's just one
day they showed up not the first day but
one so one month later we took our first
walk and everything was fine so two
weeks later we saw bodies again the same
cycle happened the cops came and we
didn't go on walks for a month we go
back on a walk again and for extra
content one and for extra context one of
my classmates uncle's seemed to be
missing for three days and then we found
his body this one was different
it wasn't covered in addy pokery adipose
a adipose and it was my classmate uncle
that had been missing for the three days
he lived in the apartment complex right
by the woods
the next month well he found a man tree
with a knife stabbed into him with a
piece of paper in his abdomen that said
hey kid stop finding my bodies and tell
your teachers to stop getting the police
you little you blunder boy I'll pass you
blind a little [ __ ] how dare you two
months go by we finally take a walk in
the woods and stumble upon a cave of
badly decomposed bodies still might
already some which I already stumbled
upon with another guy hanging with a
note that says you win little bastard
but why though well I like the young I
like the twist ending as a true story or
I don't think it was necessarily
supposed to be a true story
no I think it's I think it's submitted
it's fiction he was four years old
I mean who couldn't read and remember
things that will up four years old right
my favorite part is all first of all I'd
like to come to compliment Murph on his
vocabulary my favorite part is the fact
that he went and saw a dead body and he
kept coming back to check and there kept
turning up dead bodies yeah that's like
every day it's still there it's still
happening this is the thing this is a
thing dead bodies every day yeah you
know I'm not sure if it's gonna happen
again
go back one more week before I report
right no but a big THANK YOU to Murph
for submitting that story to us sir
Murph Anton on Twitter it seems that our
time has come but don't worry because
we're gonna be doing new dead streams
every month we're gonna switch to
Saturday with American football season
coming up so the next stream will be on
September 23rd at 2 p.m. Pacific that's
5 p.m. Eastern more are you are you guys
still gonna be on British summer time at
that point
I think I checked that booty do you
alright yeah yeah yeah and rabbit you
want to fill them in on how they can
catch the dead stream the best place to
catch us is live on a C's world channel
but if you miss it we're also on YouTube
iTunes and Google Play if you have a
story you'd like us to read here on the
show or if you find out about any news
going on in the youtube horror community
that we might want to talk about send an
email to CZ the world at gmail.com meme
says there is no british summer can you
test it that more mean you are correct
the myth it is a world isn't it but if
you were interested the music in the
dead stream is composed by the
incredible OST maker so if there are any
music fans out there looking for his
link you can find it in the description
and subscribe to us he make his channel
because it's really awesome great yes
guys please please go over and
Grimes OST maker I think he's massively
underrated and he worked so hard on the
stuff that he does a very very talented
composer rabbit where can people find
you on social media you guys can find me
on Facebook and Twitter just search lady
white rabbit and Moritz how can your
fans connect with you on the Internet
you couldn't find me uh on YouTube
Twitter and Instagram if you wanna get
some you know sneak peeks you can find
me on Facebook Google+ and Instagram has
seized world my twitter handle is
Suzie's world underscore horror and if
you guys tweets at my Twitter handle
right now with the hashtag it movie I'm
gonna be doing a video in the future
where I answer questions about the
upcoming movie and so you could have
your your tweet featured in the video
remember to subscribe to see Z's world
for new Horrors every week ring that
death bell for notifications and we'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you